PETER QUILL
I'm a tell you something...
...I'm Star-Lord.
I formed the Guardians.
Met a girl, fell in love...
...that girl died.
But then she came back.
GAMORA
[Yelling]
PETER QUILL
Came back a total dick.
GAMORA
Oh please.
NEBULA
You left out some important information
but that is the gist of it.
♫ I get the same old dreams
same time every night ♫
♫ Fall to the ground
and I wake up ♫
THE HIGH EVOLUTIONARY
My sacred mission...
...is to create the perfect society.
ROCKET
He didn't wanna make things perfect...
...he just hated things the way they are.
♫ Since you been gone ♫
♫ I'm out of my head
can't take it ♫
DRAX
I want you all to know that I am grateful
to fight beside my friends.
THE HIGH EVOLUTIONARY
Incinerate them.
[Laughing]
PETER QUILL
We were always searching for a family...
...until we found each other.
Are you ready...
...for one last ride?
DRAX
Yeah! [Laughing]
♫ Ever since you been gone ♫
ROCKET
We'll all fly away together...
...into the forever...
[Screaming]
ROCKET
...and beautiful sky.
♫ Since you been gone ♫
GAMORA
Whoever it was that you were in love with,
it sounds more like her.
- Her?
- What?
- That's ridiculous. Don't even...
- Do not bring me into this.
[Laughing]
NEBULA
Knock it off!
PETER QUILL
What?
I just never noticed how
black your eyes were.
NEBULA
They were replaced by my father
as a method of torture.
PETER QUILL
He picked a pretty set.